I'm with me now the top Republican in
the house Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
sir thank you for your time thank you
two trillion Wow wonder what that thing
looks like what will it do for the
American worker what will it do for the
American businessperson well let me walk
you through that and be very happy that
it got done today I wish it could have
got done last week because as you
reported more than 3.2 million Americans
were laid off just last week that's more
than we ever had in the Great Depression
six times is what we ever had the
financial crisis it does a number of
things first it provides a hundred and
forty billion dollars to hospitals not
just the hospitals but to the
ventilators to the P Pease what what our
medical community needs it provides
personal checks individually to families
capping out it starting phasing down at
seventy-five thousand but you know what
it does for small businesses that are
doing so much to help protect us on this
that are shutting down it provides us
resources to them it gives them a loan
but if they take that money and they pay
their employees keep them working or
they pay their rent or utilities that is
a grant they don't have to pay that park
back for the larger business we give
them a low-interest loan but also give
them a tax advantage to pay their
employees partial the retention we want
people to stay working to keep in their
jobs that these are the key elements of
this bill to actually help a few bullet
points for you on the screen jar 500
billion dollars for corporations 130
billion hospitals 150 billion local
hospitals 15 and a half billion food
stamps 1200 on a check for most
Americans extra 600 bucks friend
employed and on and on it goes
Tom Massey's a Republican from from
Kentucky he was he had an issue with
this because he wanted everybody on the
record he didn't want just a voice vote
here's what he said when asked about it
just last hour well they're trying to
cover up their votes they had enough
people there to pass the bill but they
still refused to have a recorded vote
and they told me they were trying to
protect members so this went back and
forth over night again today he was
saying put it on the record he blames
you and speaker Pelosi for that
shortfall as he considers it what about
that well that's very unfortunate as you
know we have a number of members who
have the virus number of members are
quarantined if you're in New York City
you can't even make it
down we're going to fly through the
major airports that have problems of
coming through we have people who have
their spouses who are pregnant who have
their parents who live with them so it's
a challenge to make sure to come back
but we want to make sure this was passed
we knew the Democrats had held this up
we could have got it done probably in
the other place earlier in the week but
we'd had to have everybody on the record
you know what we were able to do we
didn't pass it with unanimous consent I
would never agree to that but we were
able to have three hours of debate we
had a voice vote for those who weren't
able to make it they could actually put
across the desk how they would stand on
the how they would stand on the bill but
what happened here with which Massie was
able to do bring a number of people back
we couldn't get everybody into the
chambers because of where we were but
now you have a number of people flying
back to their home cities after being
together tightly I tirely understand and
respect the position you take with that
and I guess what he's saying is two
trillion dollars we never been here
before and you should be able to reflect
that in the vote counter that's that's
exactly what we were able we're able to
achieve that because you voted on the
bill you have a record across the desk
and you have three hours of debate we
want to do that as they already have
been told about a phase for what would
be in a phase four at this point well I
would hope anybody that's talking about
a phase four would pause right now we
have just passed three bills as you said
spent two trillion dollars in this bill
billions of dollars in the other bill
let's let them go to work first so let's
be targeted on where we're going to
spend money let's make sure this is
actually working in the process and be
smart get the data back of where if we
do need more help to be able to use that
but not just throwing money at it let's
make sure we're doing it correctly thank
you sir for your time Kevin McCarthy on
the hill